Hi everyone, it's Jerry. I have an instructive game to share with you from the 2023 St. Louis
Rapid and Blitz event. This is a Rapid game between Fabiano Caruana on the white end and
Alireza Firouzja. The game kicks off with a Ruy Lopez Berlin defense, a near-perfect
game ahead here by Firouzja. With this speedy time control, 25 minutes, 10 second increment,
it only adds an exclamation point to this near-perfect game. We continue with the ultra-solid
d3, preventing any Nxe4 lines, avoiding the familiar famous Berlin endgame. The main imbalance
we see is the bishop for knight exchange. Black works with the bishop pair. In the game
we continue with h3. e5 is poison, defended indirectly. Nxe is losing to Qd4, a familiar
double attack. So it is h3, preventing a pin. Now the e-pawn is defended directly, Nc3,
and where else for the light-square bishop? If you go to e6, that would hang the e-pawn.
Qe2, queenside castles. Not the most common side to castle on. Why is it more appealing here? Well,
there's already half-open file for black, and the rook is on it. Be3, black preserves the bishop
pair. Says my a-pawn is poison. Is that really true? It is. In the game a3 is played. If you
take the a-pawn, b6, Kb7, goodbye bishop. So here we go, a3, Kb8, and in the game it's Nd2,
one of the top moves in this position is Nd2. Another top move is to castle queenside. Bring
it to a same-sides castles position. This is not what we experience in this game. We're going to
see an opposite-sides castles position where this h3 pawn is a great liability. Black will find it
much easier to crack open a file towards the white king in large part because of this pawn.
Now, do know white can castle queenside here without fear of a sacrifice on a3. If black
goes in for this, why is it not working? Well, this fork can be met with Kd2, defending the knight.
Alright, in this game it is Nd2. Be6 watches out over a couple of the knight jumps, and in this
game we have b4. So when b4 is played, in almost all cases we could safely assume that the white
king is going to castle kingside. But surprisingly enough, there are variations where white can still
castle queenside. Now, they normally don't go hand-in-hand, b4 and queenside castles, but I
will be highlighting a variation where that is still possible and preferable. Again, this is
going to be a great liability for the white king once castled on the kingside. White's attempt in
this game is to try and crack open a file towards the black king. So we have g6. Black is now taking
steps to get the knight into f4. g6 supports that knight jump. From here it's Rb1. So clearly there's
no queenside castles as a possibility now. This is where the computer says you could still castle
queenside, oddly enough, with b4 in there. What does this look like? Here's the suggestion. Knight
c4, take out the knight, there's a threat to trap the bishop, make some room, and then it says hang
a right. Again, not very common to play in this way, but again it does not want to bring it to
an opposite sides castles position. In this game we have Rb1, knight h5, kingside castles, and it's
a race. Who's going to be able to crack open a file first? Activate the rooks. f6, top move. This
is one of many top moves by Firouzja. This is paving the way for queen f7 to defend the knight,
which enables g5 and then knight f4. If captured, you could consider taking with the g-pawn now,
and there's an open g-file to work with. A really nice maneuver here, this f6. Rook on f to d1,
queen f7, f3, and the knight hops in right away. So I found this a little bit interesting, why one
more move was not maybe played first, like g5 and then hop in here, preparing to take towards the
center and get that g-file. Why is black maybe drawn to hopping in straight away once f3 is in?
I think in a way black may be saying, you know what, now that you've weakened this square here,
if you go ahead and take my knight now, I do have this square to work with. Maybe there's
possibilities to maneuver a bishop into this weak square, and still there are ways to crack
open a file on the kingside. g4 is still going to be there landing a fork now that f3 is in,
so you could still capture in either direction with the e-pawn or maybe the g-pawn. In this game,
he hops in straight away. Queen f2, there's pressure on the pawn, defended with b6, and now
a4. So white has something to bite at, but again, it's a race. Here comes g5, a5. Let me throw a pop
quiz your way. How would you respond to this last move? Feel free to pause the video. Okay,
Firouzja ignores it. He continues with his own advance, h5. The sacrifice on this square is
not working. So if white chops away like this, you have the queen sliding over to defend. So
very resourceful move here. In this game, it's bishop takes knight, and now we have pawn on e
takes. So initially, this kind of juked me. I wasn't prepared to see this particular capture.
I just figured you take towards the center, get that open G file, but in a way, I guess black
maybe says, I'm going to still get a file opened, g4 is going to hit, the g file will be peeled open,
one or more files will be peeled open, and I'm going to be trading additional pawns, and that's
in general good news for the side with the bishop pair. So while the file doesn't open up straight
away, when it does open, it's going to be that much more effective. In this one, we have d4.
Black is there first. g4 met with h4. The g file is going to open up. Let's get to the g file. Takes
on b6. Queen f1. This is not anything serious. Black is already there first, taking on f3. Knight
takes f3. If you tried to sneak in, ignoring black's play here, queen a6, there's rook takes
pawn, and if you really wanted to scare the queen away, you could withdraw the bishop. But yeah,
queen a6 is far from working here. Maybe if the rook was already on the a file, but not the case.
In this one, it is the recapture on f3, and now active defense against any queen a6. A nice forward
move, bishop c4. Hits the queen. Queen goes to e1. Rook g3. I mean, just look at the
rook positions here. 27 moves in. Barreling down against the white king, and these guys are
staring at white pawns. The knights are on their favorite squares, but this is all about
rook play from here. Completely crushing position now for team black. King h1, out of the pin,
there was a threat to take the knight. Queen d7. Now, if white in this position, let's say,
played rook a1, what move would you play here? Feel free to pause the video. Okay,
there's a nice tactic that black is setting up by moving the queen to d7,
and that is the sacrifice on g2. Rook takes rook. Queen h3 leads to mate. If you don't play rook h2,
queen takes on g2 as mate. And if you do play here, it's just going to be
mate one move later, like that. So that's not a good idea. King h2 defends against
possible queen h3 moves once this pawn is removed. Interestingly enough, you could still...
there's many ways to approach this position. It says you could still smash through
on g2 a couple times, and then sweep in with the queen, taking the knight next.
Okay, in this one though, we have simply rook takes knight. Pawn takes rook. Rook g3,
threatening mate. The king goes back to the corner, allowing the rook to cover the check.
But now the f-pawn falls and both. There was one too many threats. The knight is hit.
There's also the idea to still sweep into h3, or even land a fork. If white tried knight e2,
here, we could have the check. Another check and rook h3. Game over here for team white.
What's tried? Rook h2. Covers the check, but black still has the rook f1 move, winning the queen.
So that's what we have. This one, if it's a longer game, it would probably already be...
white would probably have already thrown in the towel at this stage here after f3. But at this
moment, they're both under a minute, so I believe many of these... the remainder of this game is just
played on out of momentum, completely winning for black.
f3 threatens the rook. If you move the rook, the queen would sweep into h3, so
white shuts down this diagonal. Pawn takes, knight e4. We get into a rook versus... or excuse me,
a queen versus two rooks position. It's a queen and three pawns versus the two rooks,
and soon it's going to be a queen and four pawns. Completely winning. There's only one
sensitive point on black's side, c7. Even if white directs both rooks there, the queen can easily
defend along this diagonal. No problems here for team black, so let's get these final moves in
here. Nice and cozy, no checks with the king on b7, and the plan is just march this only
passed pawn. And there's no stopping it. At this stage, white simply throws in the towel.
Soon enough, this pawn is going to cost white one of these rooks. Completely winning position
for Firouzja, who played with a 99% accuracy. What'd you think of this one?
Anyhow, feel free, as usual, to leave any feedback to this video in the comments section below.
I hope you enjoyed it, and maybe took a thing or two away. That's all for now. Take care. Bye.